ladies and gentlemen i have heard that
toss a coin to your witcher song
non-stop since we put up that reaction
last week thank you guys so much for
clicking on this video if you can go
ahead and use some chaos magic on that
little like button that'd be amazing
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next witcher episode is up
because these are very enjoyable after
hawkeye comes out these are probably
gonna move to tuesdays or thursdays and
then eventually we'll do two weeks to
catch up to season two full-length watch
logs we're gonna sync up with that damn
time coder over at our patreon page
cover so many shows were there with the
same tier you get the option for both
reaction highlights and watch logs
included that's right you funky monkeys
thanks to the boys at prepper for
writing down these highlights you sexy
sons of [ __ ] anyhoo let's get into
action
yeah magic
which is
[Music]
it's a monster
good luck
i swear witcher that's what got me i
swear i saw it i swear by my screen a
different witcher and he's not blonde
three thousand orange
up from
this witcher already feels a lot more
cold
i'm not talking about the weather
oh
oh oh yes hello there
[Music]
he's more sweaty than when he fights
well yeah that's easy
making love takes some effort
a few miners rounded up three thousand
orange to have it killed
your boy took the coin and run the vlog
the victor laika the vodka cranberry the
the vadillac vervalic the nun your car
killed of a cuddle
for cud like the cuddle so you decide to
kill your king
great plan
your kind already swindled us once i
take payment after the job is done and
for a third of the price an apology
that's a good deal absolutely yeah why
not give a try
chris marigold
i serve king foltest sleep with her
and i don't want you to kill the beast
i want you to help me save it
this is a turn of events
but good luck to freak mutations
they can't be cured well good thing it's
not a view good luck oh what an easier
name to remember
so looking forward to seeing ever good
luck oh wow
you let them believe that he fled with
that coin
that's even worse making us all look bad
his heart's missing along with his liver
only one creature i know is that
peculiar estriga the only way to make
one is through a curse
but the curse didn't stop without her
it turned her daughter into a monster
her daughter this drink is a princess
royal monster wow like a whole lot of
lore in five minutes there
oh
[Music]
good for you
how is everyone watching
it's an eyes wide shut party
i just want to show everybody how well
i'm doing right now so i invited
everyone i know
this is no game captain
tonight is a full moon and geralt has
already proved himself to be invaluable
i believe urgency warrants flexibility
in court decor now we got to be
technical about this
princess arda was the people's angel
who'd wish to murder her what about her
lover
idol courtesans trading out boredom for
jealousy i don't know i mean
rotten muscle
bent bones
two spidery legs claws dragging in the
dirt and overgrown abortion enough
whoa
did he be being here he used the voice
and also probably he did
you learned that your sister was
murdered
and you didn't even flinch but the
moment i mentioned the girl's father
[Music]
king vilfriel prefers mages from his
kingdom and jennifer was born in
vanguard the only thing cintra hates
more than mages is elves
jennifer's of elven blood oh [ __ ] she's
like super protective
king fergus chose this
not me king ferguson
what are you talking about
awkward
efforts in cintra prevent the
brotherhood from placing a mage with
elven blood in hayden's court
how could you tell them
i did not it's trigger-ported
strike a [ __ ]
her man did
right yeah he's a traitor
yeah spilled that info
they just abandoned their posts i'm
pretty sure voltas is the father
oh wow
this episode of shaw's so cool
documentation that proves he's the
father it's a written sex tape queen
mother cursing her own children for
their affair sensei wanted that is
getting rid of the child what was your
relationship to ella oh i like to think
that she saw me
as a confidant there's only one wrinkle
though
your scent was on her sheep i knew it i
knew it
oh no
you cursed the woman you loved my cursed
fault not her you could have just
exposed the affair and heard adder
never her memory will not be solid not
while i'm alive to protect you're doing
a great job you're not gonna be alive
very long
oh
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i had no way of knowing how
the information would be used
but neither did you do not turn this on
me
uh
we can be together we can forge a whole
new destiny
a life holding dustbands while you push
off forgotten bones
that's not destiny
it's slow suicide i will not be schooled
by a man who pimps the world to some
romantic adventure damn i love this
dialogue yeah you know victimhood is not
your color your hero isn't yours
[Music]
you're just angry because you lost your
chance to be beautiful
oh
you going for the shake
no amount of power or beauty will ever
make you feel worthy of either
dude she's my favorite character
absolutely
she's my favorite character
let's take a rest damn
bored of dancing
full test leave your such a bee
show my dumb degrees some respect
okay
two very different timelines it's good
to know
okay i need time to prepare the herbs
that won't be necessary don't be foolish
i can't be awake during the procedure
i can
she can handle pain with the best of
them she told me to wait until a full
moon to wait and then to kill it
and then i recited some silly chant and
then i bathed in the lamb's blood until
the sun rise until the rooster crowed
three times that's it
what was the charm it was alvin um
oh my god it was jennifer oh
oh yeah maybe maybe yeah
velcro
not happy to hear that i heard those
words before what more can i do nothing
unless you can keep a streaker out of
her crypt until a [ __ ] rooster crows
three times you're gonna have to fight
until dawn
huh i'm gonna have to power up
leave my eyes
these as well
you're gonna do this awake
this is a badass to be reborn
you will bear no more
oh
no i wasn't looking at her boobs there
were boobs yes look at her eyes
[Laughter]
oh no
gross
no no no
oh you're so dead
[Laughter]
what is that wow
oh my goodness
wow
awesome
oh my god the umbilical cord oh no i got
the umbilical cord
oh that is twisted oh my god i love it
it's so crazy
out of the screams it's like an scp
creature
yeah
man ancient creepypasta
wow
[Music]
looks like weasel from uh oh suicide
squad
no this is like the cringe episode
so what are they gonna do use all of her
uterus to make her over
ugh
drool on them
wow
what is awesome
i think it knocked it out oh my god
that's disgusting
what are they doing i think that was a
uterus oh my god
so much happening in this woods
oh god
nice
wolf heads
whoa
[Music]
oh my god
grab her by the court
has their hunch pack fixed i'm not sure
that was wild
yeah
we're still like beautiful pristine and
eloquent
cut in between two excruciating
sequences both involving transformation
oh
no
[Music]
how old is she
oh [ __ ] oh no god oh no no no
dude
[Music]
oh you got me [ __ ] me no
you tell me after all that
oh man you about to see hot and improved
you're gonna wish you didn't pick on the
nerdy girl at school
[Music]
make your entrance
gonna be the promise carrie now all she
had to do was take those glasses off and
pull her hair down that's
a classic nerd wow
makeover gorgeous
oh hey we're gonna have some decisions
though ain't you buddy
what sort of a king refuses a dance with
one of his subjects on your lead your
excellence oh damn
i already loved her personality
but now she's the full pack
[Laughter]
you heal quite nicely my princess i've
arranged for her to stay a while with
the sisters of melatelli the honorable
lord ostrich gave his life to slay the
vucatlak
miners are gathering war for a statue
toss a coin to your witcher
what come on
she'll let her have it
i feel something out there waits for you
something more
more dialogue in season two
oh yeah what timeline is she on like is
she in the past wouldn't hurt tell the
audience
[Laughter]
spell it out for me
which are cut between two women
whoa
oh it's messed up
[Music]
not to mention the amount of times he's
risked his life
it's like frodo and sam wise
damn this is like
it was crazy about this show for like a
for a streaming show one that where you
they release all the episodes at once
it doesn't feel like they kind of show
you it feels like it could be a weekly
release well yeah just how epic and
scale and how complete each episode
feels you know yeah cause it's like
they're they connect enough but they're
also anthology enough that it doesn't
seem like they're trying to make you
binge it
yeah that's what i mean yeah
um so wow i'm really enjoying this show
a lot i'll tell ya
wow whatever you guys already thought
jennifer was hot
yeah
i liked her i wasn't i would say she was
hot
i mean all kinds of people are hot man
but you know like even
early on i don't know if it's in the
reaction highlights just because you
know
i don't want to get demonetized
too much i don't really run the risk
every time i cover something like this
but yeah in that open ceiling
you know yeah she's got a hunchback a
little bit of a
little bit of some uh crooked jaw thing
going on but she ain't like horrendous
to look at no she's still still
attractive she's got great personality
as well and a nice heart she's my
favorite character before she got you
know
before
yeah yeah
for sure
she's one of the most moving characters
on the show absolutely oh yeah out of
any character she's the one that you're
just so emotionally connected to
like
even even the leap from what where she
was in the prep of the last episode to
where she is now
someone who's a lot more taking a stand
more confident more stern
you buy it just even one episode arc you
know even though there's been some time
span that's happened
and she's such a phenomenal actress oh
yeah
i just didn't realize i hired a
supermodel
that's good the power of freaking like
so directed
that's true i and i i i i'm now very
curious to know what
how like you know obviously like her
hunchback is a bit of some kind of
appliance but
like her jaw and all that like i'm
curious to know what was her own
contortion versus what was like aided by
you know you're kind of locked into a
position from you know special effects
makeup or whatever uh yeah i remember
hearing that it caused her some real
problems some real physical problems uh
she developed something i want to say
she does some form of like scoliosis due
to it i can say hey man like you you
adopt a physical uh you know a physical
ailment or or restriction like that for
a role and you do it so much like
sometimes it can have an effect on your
actual physiology beyond that the makeup
holds weight and so you're you're
literally just you position your body in
this place where you have weight holding
it yeah so it really hurts a lot yeah
and then you're straining that muscle
yeah yeah you're contorted all day and
but probably good
but damn
it
cleans up nice cleans up nice
good makeover
good makeover
what i love about the transformation too
is you're like
yeah [ __ ] show what's up get hot
make him
lied to you and talked [ __ ] on you and
held you back and underestimated you
this is she really is like a trial by
fire and it's fascinating because it
feels like a natural most literally
yeah absolutely and yeah in the course
of two episodes
like yeah i bought that whole evolution
i would not be able to keep up with this
show if there were not subtitles it's
true that
yeah like they keep tossing around
different words first they introduced
the volkswagen or whatever the hell that
thing's called
the voltron the volca covenant
i'm like all right get your listening
years ago what is this thing that we're
going to learn about
oh no it's not bad at all okay all right
forget all never mind
let's learn a new creature now much
easier much easier you could definitely
remember a stricter a lot easier
yeah
yeah and then well not to mention like
you got one character who's like fully
involved with one half of the plot and
then one a single scene you have that
character show up as a child and you're
like wait a minute hold on where are the
timelines other than this is way in the
past
that was one thing that got semi-ruined
for us uh early on was that there's that
it deals with like multiple timelines
but i didn't realize
fully that oh we are
we are already there
so made it easier to adjust to that
moment while like okay these are
different timelines yeah like it's made
it easier to know that just because we
got a heads up about it but i didn't
know that we were indeed watching
multiple like two different timelines uh
until that moment oh jennifer's in the
past yeah uh that's interesting or maybe
time works differently in the tba
time was working a little bit different
here where
time is always running at once i i don't
know i'm just going to accept it as like
the past
circle yeah yeah perhaps
but this episode was incredibly gripping
i love the landscapes love the way the
production design was
snowy dark fantasy yes
music to my ears i eat that [ __ ] up i
love environments like that it's it has
that pure like almost del toro-esque
nightmarish quality like always just in
the atmosphere of it all and henry
cavill just gets better to me every
episode yeah absolutely so good in this
like he just has so much presence
you know and and i mean enhanced by like
he's wandering around all these like
gothic abandoned caverns and castle
things but he's just so compelling
like in every moment i find it funny
that you know yeah he doesn't have
the lion's share of dialogue i mean he
talks a good amount in this episode but
he is so great even in those shots where
someone asked him a question and he
doesn't respond like he has so much
going on in his performance i think he's
got a lot of depth 100 yellow-ass eyes
of his got a lot of depth you could tell
that he's
that this is something personal for him
right off the bat right off the top of
the story of like him getting involved
in this that this is not at all about
we've seen an episode where he takes on
a job because he agreed to take on a job
with the last one yeah but here it's
like he give a [ __ ] about the money yeah
you know it's like he'll take the money
but it's not about the money yeah yeah
yeah and uh
ultimately it's about revealing the
truth and actually getting to the bottom
of this and i loved how you see him
work his
the art of dialogue throughout here how
it's
he the way he communicates with the king
the king's staff the witch
how he's literally solving a mystery
forever like a detective yeah yeah you
see more of the detective angle of him
it's very more investigative of how he's
going about it
and the way he can provoke to get the
answer he's looking for you're like oh
there's so much more to this guy than
just kill the
the mutated creatures you know but damn
when you got that mutated creature whoa
that that worked that was good you build
this creature up and boy does it deliver
absolutely like the [ __ ] keeper meets
weasel
yeah
yeah me it's like i couldn't help but
think of gabriel from malignant
yeah and uh and uh god i forget there
was a video game trailer that had like a
spider creature that was all black like
that and it was a great i hear their
their use of
i loved how they built up a just what
what is the creature we thought it was
this one thing now we know it's this
other thing they describe it as having
like oh two spider-like legs and all
these other things but when you finally
see it and they bothered to include
based off that lore of like she must
have clawed her way out of her mommy
yeah dead mom's woman said over an
abortion yeah and like it really
personifies that in a monstrous way and
it was a great i think use of creature
performance makeup sweetened here and
there by cgi but
like a really great convergence of movie
magic absolutely and i thought the way
the fight scene was done was excellent
like they had an amazing use of wire
work yeah and what i thought was really
cool something that i wasn't expecting
to feel when we're watching it
is that yes it is this monster that
appears
but they've done so much build up to it
with
asking the question and i love that they
asked the question of is there a soul to
this being yeah can it be saved can it
be saved like the king even is like it's
it still views it as his daughter
and
you know what can they do after this is
there hope if we do turn this creature
back into being human
and so when the fight is happening
i'm actually at least for me i was
actually aware of the person underneath
all this
that there's still a living soul in in
there that needs to be saved so it's
like terrifying as it is and as cool of
creature feature effects as there is to
behold i was still like
there's still a person there you're
gonna wrestle you're still gonna rescue
that person yeah you're still invested
in hopefully achieving plan a and not
having to resort to killing her plan b
yeah i just love how dirty and icky and
grimy just uh
and it and the way how like by the time
you get to the end when the when the
sunlight is peeking in and how they're
just covered in mud and oil and dirt and
it's just wet and nasty i loved it
and how after all that fighting it's his
compassion to check up on her that gets
him the most injured mm-hmm so so clever
it's clever [ __ ] man i thought this was
really clever
now i'm very much invested in it and it
really rewards audience if you pay the
[ __ ] attention like you gotta
you gotta really pick up on [ __ ] yeah
and i and i liked how they handled a lot
of that with uh the the king guy who you
know impregnated his sister and all that
and his
uh advisor because they do play on you
know your own sort of biases as you're
learning about the situation your own
suspicions and i like the way that that
came around in the way that your
attention out of those scenes and the
way that at first you see the king and
you're like ah this oh god this guy you
know you kind of uh it's easy to root
against or to have a strong sense of
disdain for that character and you know
to sympathize with the guy who was like
i loved ada and i wanted to protect her
and i have this whole other plan in mind
to expose the king and torture him and
whatnot and then by the end of the
episode you know those sympathies then
change yeah and i thought they handled
that too in a very natural way that felt
like yeah people with their own secrets
to keep in their own motivations rather
than just like oh cool plot [ __ ] you
know yeah yes
and two with geralt like i love the way
that they draw his
badassness because it's not
it's not
resting on the style to you know
communicate that it's like you know each
of these fights is a struggle in each of
these you know confrontations with these
different people is like he has to work
to you know
to carve
his path and to achieve whatever you
know task he has at hand but also yeah
it's like it's it's an effort it's an
effort it's a struggle and that's what
makes it rewarding to watch the fights
because you know if every fight was like
the end of the first episode
just a bunch of humans and girls was in
there and it's like okay we're gonna
throw some humans at this guy it's gonna
be no problems gonna be walking apart
uh but you know from the opening scene
when he's fighting whatever that like
spider creature is in the water
of the first episode
you see how do you remember that for
some reason that name really stuck in my
mind
all the other c
whatever the other thing that it wasn't
this time i just can't stick
with blabvikin's man well when that
creature appears you see that he's like
having a real struggle yeah yeah that
sets the stage for when he gets caught
in the last episode he gets his hands
tied behind his back and he has to talk
his way out of it and then here yeah
when he's involved in the fight he is
just getting messed up throughout and
that makes for the best kind of action
heroes too
of yes he does have like that great
brooding quality about him and you do
see that there's a much more
compassionate side everyone's being like
you don't feel but you know he obviously
feels
and uh yeah when you watch him get that
much injured that you feel like he has
to work for the win yeah he's not
overpowered
which is great for a guy who already has
like great strength and agility and
special
skills to really give him like these
difficult to oppose like really opposing
challenges it's awesome yeah it's that
quality of like if anyone's got this
it's geralt but also it's gonna be a
challenge you know
they sell the moment so well because
they sweep you up in its tone and
atmosphere so much
like complemented by its like orchestral
music and like it's operatic almost like
church like choir music
they they wrap you up so much in it to
the point where
when he got bit
he was like you're kidding me
i had to be like oh wait he's like the
main character he's gonna be he's gonna
be well
at the moment i was like i don't know
man multiple times maybe this is where
he died
but i like the way that they sold that
too because they actually got me worried
for him yeah and when he comes back to
consciousness i was like okay i can also
see how that's plausible and how it
would be her to you know come to his
rescue and all that i do a lot of great
world every episode introduces so much
world building already and we're only on
episode three and i'm like get your
focus on greg yeah
because they're you know they're
building up this whole family and this
this is like this kingdom here that
you're focusing on you're not even like
seeing what any of them look like the
whole time
i gotta commit all these people the
memory even though i don't have a visual
aid here to help me out well that's a
great way to put you in the character's
shoes too because yeah i mean it's at a
time where all you have to go on for a
lot of things is either the written or
spoken word until you travel a great
distance to get to where you were going
and then find those people so yeah
because you're talking about the king
you're seeing like the workers who are
thinking of going on strike you got the
staff of the king
yeah there's a rise of a rebellion
happening here if they don't solve this
problem that's gonna that's gonna unfold
and then you're talking about like the
sister and the daughter and you you
never see the sister
so you've got so many different puzzle
pieces here with this one kingdom and
you're learning all about this and
you're not even like relying on cutting
to all these visuals to help you commit
it all to memory
uh and i thought the witch character uh
who who was here was awesome i forget
her name but the one who was helping out
the witcher yeah i thought she was great
and i like that inclusion of you know
every king kind of gets their own witch
yeah they get their own merlin
essentially and their own mystical
advisor
which is a
neat detail
but yeah the the the end of the at the
end of the day oh really quick though
but how they carry over that theme
of
from the toss of coin to your butcher
part when the bard is writing a song
yeah about how like it's not the facts
that matter it's the stories and yeah
like this again he does
all his work yeah yeah like yeah they
said that they caught the the vlog
sticking and then they and they're going
to build a stack
none of it's real at all
like the terrible person's going to be
have his name honored
and
now we are here
so i thought that was like cool to have
that uh that theme carried over and for
him to just have to live with this
reality well those are good ways to
authenticate a world like that because
you know like our our world is full of
things like that very true effigies to
people that then rewrite their entire
human history
so
though what i'll say though is i think
yennefer really is the heart and soul of
the story because you have i i like
what is her name you called her
melisandre first
oh goodness to to take taissa
i thought
this scene's good at what the show was
excellent at doing is whatever scene
they're choosing they're really good at
choosing which character's perspective
you're taking on in that scene
so when they were with the
chapter the court
the the yeah the yeah is that the word
it's either chapter of court i think it
was the chapter the chapter chapter of
what the the men of the witches the
witches yeah that counsel that yeah yeah
uh when they were there and you were in
her shoes you're in her perspective and
that scene the way they handle it like
there's so much more going on underneath
the surface of these performances like
they know in the editing when to take a
beat to let you see
that there's something more here
happening underneath and it's really
good with visual storytelling like when
witcher is talking about like who this
girl might be this trigger and then they
focus on the king and you see butchers
look like oh okay he's that right away
you're like that she's the dad you know
and then there there's this little beat
that you have with
whatever her name is
jennifer's mentor essentially
where you really see oh she cares about
jennifer like she actually does and then
they go back to where jennifer
barges in the room and is pissed off at
her
and you watch how we you watch that
woman's performance of
god what is her name we gotta assign
some kind of name let's go call her
mentor for now and you see mentor
take on the same exact cadence and
demeanor that she had in the prior
episode which is a lot more cold more
strict and not showing that level of she
actually really cares about yennefer
yeah so i thought that was so cool to
toy with that perspective oh you guys
you oh you she actually does like her
and does care about some bully i mean
obviously yes but she does have more of
a heart for her than she lets on and
they let that be shown in the counsel
scene yeah when you go to yennefer
barging in she communicates the
information but she doesn't communicate
at all that she was trying to help her
she was trying to get her back and get
her to where she originally wanted yeah
to be assigned yeah she doesn't like
throw the council and she maintains the
integrity that the council is supposed
to represent yeah it hides her own
vulnerability her or her own emotions
and then yeah i love that dynamic of we
see her in a situation where she doesn't
have as much powered influence and then
when we see her back in charge with
jennifer then yeah at first she wants to
keep that facade of like i can't you
know it would almost be unprofessional
to go too deep into
you know i wanted this but they didn't
want that you know she's kind of just
trying to be straight and stern and i
love that that gives jennifer an
opportunity to really stand up then and
continue that growth through this
episode of just standing up to everyone
around her yeah man
[Music]
yeah you can see she really gets through
to her they push jennifer to the edge
and i love this character who's like
thrusted into this world
it's cursed in so many ways
and
she has a special gift so i love that
kind of character it has to go against
the hierarchy here
and prove to them that like she's going
to take this into her own hands you can
just feel that build up that she's not
going to be answering anyone
because she's dealt with pain her whole
life so she can she can deal with
torture she can deal with suffering to
get to the point where she's at like
only
only one of the witches here she's the
only one who could have handled going
under under that procedure
while still awake
because of everything she's had to deal
with god and uh but her perform like she
just lives and breathes through her eyes
that character man she's phenomenal in
that role
and surprisingly so attractive
so
yeah get over that it's just like true
that did it true that yeah
i just can't get over it it's the dark
man
naughty
that's crazy
how do you have to do a lot of character
building for the not version
you know did you make it all about your
looks
you work internally at all i don't
imagine this matches your own life
experience whatsoever so that's really
impressive acting okay
i know you have problems no one
definitely treated you this way in real
life ever no
you've just been a supermodel the day
you were born and everyone loves you in
the end
yeah it's good acting but the but all
the catharsis and the uh it always comes
through her character yes yeah yeah yeah
because she gets to she gets to be
vindicated and she gets to you know
prove people wrong and and yeah and also
you know call people out on deceit
yeah yeah that's awesome i could have
watched like the whole season with her
just uh in her other form yeah i mostly
show i was pretty like in love with her
character so much i was like oh dude we
transformed her fast yeah spit a bunch
there yeah it's all good it's all good
it's enthusiasm coming out of your mouth
but salivating for the new luck of
vienna food i know and i'm surprised
that it happens so quickly but at the
same time you know we'll see what it
does to her character i know it's like
it happened during the night this i
thought it was like you need at least 24
hours to rest before
like nope i'm good to go procedure's
gonna take like an hour
it's gonna be so bad you'll be done in
time to get back to that dance no one's
gonna hear you scream
yeah yeah we're gonna do this in the
bowels of the castle where no one can
hear yeah that david bowie like guy has
kind of had that position of lenny
kravitz and the hunger games
you know yeah makeover guy yeah he's
getting everybody ready for the big game
it's good
who knows man maybe though i mean he
said that thing to her about like you
know even if you get hot you know it's
not gonna make you feel like you
deserved it so i wonder if they're going
to use her appearance continually
as uh some kind of character beat yes
please or if she's just ultimately just
gonna be like i'm made over and now i'm
uh way better now you know
i i would expect them to go with the
nuance it was more than just her looks
you know it was all it was that's what's
cool about the development is it's about
gaining power
uh in this like she walks in the room
she's the most beautiful one yeah you
know she almost like it seems like she's
enchanted what a king guy what a great
way to make your ex jealous yeah just
walk right in transfix a candy
you know where people are like
i mean she left me i'm gonna go work out
get in shape and i'll show her
vice versa too
she did this in like one hour
yeah oh yeah watch this i'll be right
back no wonder dude's like wait what
what have i done i just saw you
damn it what have i done i literally
caused this it's all my fault
but hey you know they got to do it once
so
all right guys he had his chance i'm
sure he did multiple times some time has
passed all right guys we were talking
long enough thanks so much for being
here hit that like button subscribe
click that bell last but not least
flev doran all of us might look in the
mirror once in a while and go
i got some kind of flaw here
for you buddy
if there is a way for you to get a
makeover some kind of procedure to make
yourself better you know what i would do
i'd smack you and i go
not necessary flev
you are perfect you don't need a
makeover whatsoever you don't need no
man everyone at our patreon can get that
procedure they should they all should if
you're listening patrons
super rejects
look better look better but flev
not needed that's right buddy i'll take
down everyone just to keep you there's
no one else we want to pledge we will
cover every show at our patreon only to
keep you happy
only due to your impeccable
impossible to achieve
good
looks
i've never seen you before
but this is just kind of what i'm
thinking yeah you got to be that good
looking you just strike me as that it
just comes through in your comments i
can tell a beautiful person wrote this
you know or he looks like a striga it's
one of the two hey hey you know and if
that's the case guys no one needs to get
a procedure at our patreon because if
you want to feel better about yourself
just looking flat
the striga
you're one of the two i just don't know
which one
definitely one of the two though it's
not in the middle that's for sure
love you flem feels like she
[Music]